next class will be Tau by Miss T Sensei
from
[Music]
France do another way straight
completely straight
[Music]
my head okay so you have to put the
other hand down
here put the other hand here and
continue like that only one is not
enough only one is not
enough so I
two the same
way and
continue okay
[Music]
and you let him
cross
you come back
[Music]
after all right
immediately Bigg issue it's a
and here just with your
hips with your
hips
hi attack is very important with this
sort of technique okay if you just
attack me and stay here it's not
possible to do it
okay if he ATT me and if he turn his
hand like that it's not possible I need
a very good attack completely and the
hand so he come and he attack completely
okay that is good so I can work now
because it's he cut it completely
completely so here I put this sun slowly
please I put this sun in the middle okay
and just as the hand I put it back okay
and other hand
right yeah just to control but I stay
straight I don't take this way I don't
take this way I just in front of
him here
okay and when it it's I succeed to do
that I take the wrist and now it's basic
technique I just move my hips I just
move my
hips in a good balance
take the
W okay do it again please
[Music]
okay is it okay for everybody of course
yes okay
[Music]
yes but you come back to Kori and when
you do Kori here is completely shut if I
open I have to do something or he
continue do it okay so I have to do
something so it's the same
youi I take the w here it's not
open okay completely shut hand here I
cross
cross and
finish so be careful don't do the
technique like
that it's very dangerous
okay here completely
shut and
finish hi
[Music]
all
right okay that's un okay I just need
one point okay it's not coming here no
just here just the point of the axes of
my partner I come here I come here and
is
[Music]
finished
more so don't take the har of bner no
just here put my hand here and on of my
partner I come here
okay you do it again in that way okay
I
first
and go first and
[Music]
thank
you okay you can do immobilization I I
can I cannot do it okay my
KNE stay inside
and good C
right here if my UK is in live when I
move this hand it come back on my head
okay so I have to take this way okay
inside your bottom is down and your head
is up and not the opposite you don't
have to do that that is the rule of
thano okay head up bottom
back okay so here you have to join that
you are here you take Goku this hand
stay
inside to have a balance and to join the
technique basic technique of s here now
it's possible
okay but not I do wrong
side not that
there is no balance here okay I have to
stay inside with this
hand and stay stay stay here no it's
possible okay okay please do it
again uh it's important when you attack
it's important if you stay with your
partner in the attack okay when you
attack it's not only yok Mani
Ori when you attack it's during all the
technique all along the technique okay
so for example you attack okay and here
I know there is nothing okay when I move
my arm he stay no no stay in the same
place he stay in the same place okay if
he if you do like that okay I don't
interest me because he don't attack me
okay so it interest me if here he is
with me I know that if I put this arm
here it come back on my face that is
interesting okay so here
first good attack so you take the the wi
like Goku the same one okay Goku you put
your arm inside and now you go up and
you arrive to EO side you can put Knees
Down I I cannot but you can okay if you
want here guu hop and stay here the ru
of
it's the W up of okay theist up and head
down okay it's a rule here one
two waist h b down here
okay hi
don't
[Applause]
no thank you